so this is kind of interesting up top
I'm me
did not expect an applause there what I
mean is I'm me I'm really me I'm not you
know like a Tupac hologram like he's
gonna rap it's me and I'm me all the
time that's really my point
I'm always me I go to bed me I wake up
me I'm me all day I'm never not me and I
know that's obvious but I actually think
that's one of the more interesting
aspects about being human is that you
just like me you're you all day no one
will ever know you as well as you know
you because you're the only one that's
up here
all the time hearing every
thought just like let's have Milk Duds
for breakfast shut up me and like you
know yourself so well so other people
sometimes get an idea of you or like
sometimes people say that I'm nice right
I am for the most part but I'm still
surprised when people say that every
time I'm like really you think I'm nice
how do you think of that so nice I'm not
thank you because up here I'm everything
nice mean happy sad smart confused
stupid horny always horny
every time I do something nice there's
also another thought deep down that only
I get to hear that it isn't that nice
like hmm I bet it'd be real easy to
steal money from old people
confused tired weak grip those are the
thoughts that only I know about they're
so deep in there they're just for me
well until I shared them on national
television
that joke was that example was just a
joke Nana do you guys are thinking about
her like if we assemble a posse where's
the nearest nursing home 50 bucks for
everybody and hard candy all around
other things too like people will say
I'm funny nice people tell me I'm funny
and yeah I can be but for every time I'm
funny there's like at what a billion
times that I'm not in the course of a
day you see what I want you to see but
I'm there for those private little
moments cuz I'm always with me I know
how unfunny I can be I was there in the
burro in the Starbucks talking with the
barista just like small huh why are you
calling at all
Tom means big yeah this Tommy big
shouldn't it be largest mm-hmm she
looked at me like you're a venti
and I was there for that not funny so
when people are funny they're like yeah
good thing they weren't there for
Starbucks in a perfect world would be
accepted for being our complete selves
for being nice and for having weird
thoughts about jerking off in the office
one seater that's what makes
relationships so great your partner
loves you for who you really are
and you no longer have a need to jerk
off in the office ones to get hurt but
you guys really put in Reverse on
jerking off in the office one feeler
these are thoughts I haven't done it
this week
relationships are where you going from
being me all day to being we all day
isn't that sweet what do I work for home
art it's true cuz they get to see all
that including the time you did
that monologue where you said jerking
off in the office one-seater twice
because your other half will see you
your best when you're dressed up in a
suit for a night on the town and at your
worst throwing up in a baby carriage